THE BLUE  IT BACK AND
TATAR AND BACKHAND!
HE SCORES!T.
TATAR IS WIDE  A GREAT
DEFENSEMAN FOR SO MANY  TO THE .
.
CROSSES UP WITH VESEY. BACK.
JAKE BEAN WITH A SHOT THAT DUMP.
DAWSON MERCER, FOOTE HRWARD, HA
MULTIPLE POINTS IN EACH OF HIS
LAST TWO SIEGENTHALER.
NATE BASTIAN GETS THE PUCK.
DEVILS GET A GREAT ONE THERE.
JIMMY VESEY THE BLUE
JACKETS REMAINS SI MADE A GREAT
PLAY AS HEOUT?
OH, MY!
THAT IS A
OFFENSE AND IT KIND THE OPPOSIT
FROM THE DEVILS.
>> Steve: MERCER LONG PASS AND
SHOOTING AND RANG IT OFF THE
PIPE!
CROSS-ICE SPEED TO MERC ON THAT.
>>
SIEGENTHALER.
DEVILS GAIN THE JONES.S. IT TO .
I CAN'T SEE IF
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS TRYING TO
GET AT BASTIAN.
BECAUSE OF HIS GREATARANGOVICH,.
YOU KNOW ABOUT DOUGIE HAMILTOON.
LOOKED LIKE KORPISALO GOT A
PIECE OF IT.
THERE IS K
COLUMBUS.
PASS INTENDED FOR LAINE.
TAKEN BY THE MEN ON THE
IC
DEVILS.
PUNCHED AHEAD FOR HUGHES
HE ENDS UP GETTING IT OUT TO
SUBBAN.
WENT HE SCORES!
DOESN'T GET OUT OF POSITION.
JACK